good afternoon welcome to the last day
uh you made it this far and you're still
attending sessions that means you must
still have some energy left to learn uh
which is great I hope uh something
useful will come out of this session for
you uh and I know we all just ate lunch
so you might be a little sleepy after
this so I'll try and keep it really
interesting today we're going to talk
about how to build a distributed uh how
to not build a distributed monolith or
in other words how to avoid doing
microservices completely wrong I want to
start out by telling you a little bit of
a story I'm a consultant uh I am one of
the owners of a consulting company
called trail head and we help our
clients build custom software
applications and very frequently we'll
have clients come to us like we did
recently uh that have built what they
call a microservices application and
often times they'll come to us kind of
right at the end of the project just
before it's supposed to launch and
they'll say something like this client
told us which is uh we have a little bit
of a performance issue with just a
couple of the end points that we'd like
you to get your help to fix before we go
live uh so with this client that came to
us recently that was also the case and
we started looking at their
code and started looking at the
architecture of the system that they had
built and it didn't take us very long to
realize that what they had built was not
at all microservices what they had built
was
actually a distributed monolith now if
you're not familiar with this term
already I hope you are by the end of the
talk today this is the bad guy this is
the villain in our story today the
distributed monolith that's why I put it
in this scary font are you all
scared uh this is far from the only time
this has happened this has happened so
many times uh with clients coming and
saying we built this micro mic service
it's not working well and then we look
at it and say oh this isn't
microservices at all this is a mess and
uh it happen so many times that I
started thinking I need to start
collecting and sharing this information
with the world uh so that's what I'm
doing here this is the talk that I
created based on that
inspiration I'm going to talk about a
bunch of things today but the main thing
we're going to talk about is I'm going
to share with you the 10 most common
mistakes that I see our clients making
when they try to build micros services
and end up building something much worse
called a distributed monolith hopefully
this will help you avoid making these
same mistakes a little bit about me
before I get started my name is Jonathan
Tower I go by J for short uh as I
mentioned I'm a founding partner and
principal consultant at Trailhead we do
custom application development
Consulting uh you can contact me at all
these places online if you're interested
in getting connected afterwards I've
also got this GitHub l link here which
will take you to these slides if you're
interested in looking at these again
later I'll also post these on the slack
Channel if you're on that I'm also a
Microsoft MVP uh nine years in a row
foret uh started out in asp.net and then
uh that got merged and now I'm ONN net
and uh one other thing I just wanted to
mention on this slide I'll show this
slide again at the end if you want to
get any of this information again but
something special I like to offer to
anyone that comes to one of my talks is
a free consultation I know we'll have
some time for Q&A hopefully afterwards
here if you want to come up and talk to
me afterwards you're welcome to do that
too sometimes maybe we're a little too
embarrassed about the problems that
we're having with our software and we're
not uh don't feel free to do that in
public or maybe there's something
proprietary or some context that you
need to give me first uh if you want to
do a free 30 minute session with me and
we can talk through what you're facing
uh be happy to do that you can go to
this bitly link or this QR code and uh
sign up for
free all right so before we get started
with the 10 most common mistakes that I
see let's make sure we're talking about
the same thing with some definitions so
let's start with the definition of a
monolith monolith is a traditional
architecture of software development if
you've been doing this for very long
you've probably built many monolith
applications before it's easy to get
confused nowadays uh there's so many
talks even at conferences as good as NDC
there'll be a lot of talks about
microservices and it's this buzzword and
you start to get the impression that
everything should be a microservice and
nothing should be a monolith and
hopefully the one thing I really want to
convince you of today in this talk is
that that is not the case that monoliths
can be good too in fact we've been
building scalable monoliths for decades
now before microservices was ever an
option they're actually much easier to
build than microservices are uh they're
actually also better at something called
Data latency which is basically how long
it takes from when you enter the data to
when it's available stored and available
for the whole application to use so
there's a lot of pluses to a
monolith uh there are disadvantages as
well one of them is that if you want to
make a change to a monolith even if
you're changing something small like the
name of a button or the word that shows
on a button that requires you to change
the whole application right we've all
had this before where maybe there's
misspelling in one of our applications
and you need to update it while you have
to rebuild the entire application and it
has to go through your release Pipeline
and you have to update the entire
application just to change that one
button so that's kind of a downside to
the
monolith that does uh also mean that
there's more tight coupling between the
components of a monolith which means
it's possible to write some code that
brings down the entire thing right if
you have a class that's used in every
single part of your application uh you
can imagine like a logger or something
like that you can imagine that if you
put some bad code in there that that
would bring down your entire
application and then uh finally one of
the disadvantages is that you have to
use the same technology stack when
you're doing a a monolith you have to
build the entire thing using the same
stack of Technology because the whole
thing is uh built and deployed
together you also uh this really works
best if you have a small team that is
all working on the same thing and it
doesn't work as well if you're trying to
have a huge team with lots of different
people focused in just specific areas
working in just their specific areas of
expertise what's a typical monolith is
going to look something like this it's
going to have clients that are
connecting to a mid middle tier uh part
of the application and then some sort of
a data store like a relational database
or a nosql
database this is your typical
application architecture
one of the common reasons that I get
that people say that they're using the
microservices architecture is because
they want their application to be
scalable now that is true that
microservices are more scalable in some
ways than monoliths but monoliths are
scalable too and you probably all know
this I'm probably repeating information
that you know already but you can scale
up a monolithic application by adding
more processor cores more memory you can
also scale up the database portion the
same way right you can make a more beefy
server or virtual server to run your
application and you can scale it up that
way you can also scale horizontally when
you're doing a monolith this is most
commonly done with things like load
balancing on the middle tier or if
you're talking about on the back end
storage you're going to use something
like data sharding where you're
splitting your data up and storing it
into different data stores depending uh
based on one key or other like your user
ID or your customer ID or something like
that that uh is a good key to kind of
split your data up based off of so
there's lots of ways to scale a
monolithic
application uh and I want to underscore
that just because I hear that reason so
much and it ends up often times uh as I
talk more to those people I'll find out
that it's the only reason that they
built microservices and it turns out
it's actually not a good fit for their
needs there's actually a couple
different kinds of monoliths uh
hopefully you've been hearing me say
this already that monoliths aren't
always bad so there is something that I
call a modular monolith this is
hopefully the type of application you've
had the chance to work on before where
you can go into the code you can change
things really easily you don't have to
change things in five places to make one
simple change uh changing something in
one place doesn't break something in
another place right it's basically a
well-designed modularly
created low coupling monolith it's still
a monolith if you have to compile the
whole thing together and the whole thing
goes through one devops pipeline to be
released it's still a monolith if you
have to uh release the entire
application just to update one part of
it but it could be a really
well-designed monolith and therefore it
would be a modular monolith now there's
another kind of monolith which is I
think the one that we all think of when
we hear that word monolith which I call
the ball of mud monolith
you know you've worked on one of these
before if you go into the code to try
and make a change over here and then you
find out from QA or from your users that
you broke five things over here uh if
you know that you're working on a ball
of mud monolith if every time you make a
change you break things that you don't
realize you're breaking and your
customers your end users are mad at you
all the time because there always seems
like you're making the system worse
instead of better it's probably because
it's a poorly designed monolith now that
doesn't mean that microservices is a bad
fit for you if you're on a ball of mud
monolith you might be a better fit uh
for that project to go to a modular
monolith architecture and it might be a
better fit to go to microservices by the
end of this talk I hope you will have an
easier time identifying those
situations next definition I want to
cover is microservices themselves now I
think there's a very interesting
definition of this that Google uses
internally for their teams they refer to
the definition of microservices as both
the architecture and organizational
approach to software development notice
that it's both an architecture and an
organizational approach why do I want to
underscore that because I bet all of us
before I said that think of
microservices primarily as an
architectural approach right but it's
very important I think to realize that
not only is it an architectural approach
but it also requires you to reorganize
your team your processes to actually fit
microservices the rest of the definition
Google uses internally is uh the it's a
kind of software approach and team
organization that leads to software
composed of small Loosely coupled
services that communicate with each
other through well-defined
messages and are owned by small
self-contained teams so that's back to
that organizational structure that I
mentioned right small
self-contained teams there's a lot of
benefits to microservices if you have a
well-designed microservice and part of
your application gets a lot more traffic
than another part of your application
you can scale up just that one part of
your application so that's more like a
targeted scalability or Precision
scalability it's also possible to take
part of your application down for
maintenance while another part stays up
and completely operational imagine you
have part of your application that's
taking order orders maybe you do
millions of orders an hour and you don't
want to lose money uh by taking that
down for maintenance but you have other
parts of the application that need to be
updated more frequently maybe like user
profiles needs to be updated
occasionally well you don't want to take
down your ability to take orders in the
middle of the day just so you can update
the user profile part of your
application so micros services are
really great at that uh of course I
mentioned before different technology
Stacks that's possible
in microservices I don't see a lot of
teams doing this but you could imagine
that maybe part of your team is more
familiar with Java that's okay you can
be friends with them anyway right maybe
part of your team's more into net those
are obviously the cool people on your
team uh maybe someone is into you know
something cool like rust uh or go but
you could have different parts of your
organization that has different
expertises and they could build their
part of the application in in whatever
technology stack is is the best fit for
their part of the
business and then also I mentioned the
team organization so if you're doing
microservices it makes a lot of sense to
have separate teams who are each focused
on different microservices and they
become experts in that part of the
business and really there's very little
need for them to cross over into other
parts of the
business uh so then the villain of our
story The distributed
monolith what is a distributed monolith
well nobody set out hopefully to build a
distributed monolith but what you when
you get a distributed monolith usually
it's because you set out to build
microservices but you created them in a
way that were tightly coupled and when
you deployed a tightly coupled
application in a distributed way it
became much worse than if it was just a
monolith or obviously if it was a pure
microservices this is what a typical uh
distributed monolith is going to look
like uh I'm sorry this is what a typical
microservice architecture is going to
look like uh a typical distributed
monolith architecture is going to look
just the same except because you're
setting out to build microservices but
it's going to fail in the sense that all
of the services are going to be talking
to each other maybe they're going to be
accessing each other's databases maybe
they're going to be sending synchronous
HTTP rest calls to each other uh all of
these types of things create coupling
between these applications and we're
going to talk about a lot of examples of
this as we're going into detail uh now I
specifically left the event bus off of
this slide but I want to show you that
most people who set out to do
microservices will include an event bus
because they will have read on a blog or
something that you're supposed to have
some sort of an event bus or a queue and
so they will include it but then because
they're sort of used to building a
monolith they know how to have one
module call another module and so
they'll write their code the way that
you would write WR a monolith and
they'll just have one service calling
another maybe the most popular way I've
ever seen a microservice built is this
one I love to show the slide because
once I get to this point most people are
tracking with me and I get so many
smiles when I put this slide up because
I think uh people come up to me
afterwards and say this is what my
company is building right now it's uh
microservices but the DBA when we told
him we were building microservice he
said Over My Dead Body
right and I can give dbas a little bit
of credit for that because they've been
trained their entire careers and their
entire education not to repeat data
right normalize data don't have multiple
copies of data don't try and synchronize
data all the time try and get it all
into one place put it into nice
normalized tables with perfect
relationships between each other and
they're trying to protect that right so
you come to them and say hey we're going
to do microservices and they say well in
that middle tier you can do whatever
kind of crazy architecture you want but
you're not touching my database right so
this is what I see frequently at
companies and they end up saying look
what we'll do is you can just put
everything in the database and I'll set
it up the way that I normally would and
all these different applications can
call it and that'll that'll be
microservices what we're going to look
at today how this creates a lot of
coupling between these applications that
makes them a distributed monolith so if
you organize these a little bit on a
graph the ball of mud monolith is
monolithic physically it's deployed as a
single piece but it's also logically
monolithic everything is tied together
so tight you can't really separate
things you can't update things
easily the modular monolith which is a
perfectly great architecture it's more
modular modular in the way that it's
logically organized but it's deployed as
a single piece so it's still physically
monolithic the distributed monolith is
what you get when you try to create
create
microservices but you end up creating
them in a logically monolithic way with
all the code referencing all the other
services and so you end up with it being
physically distributed but still
logically it's
monolithic and then you end up with true
microservices up there in the corner
where you've got it both physically
distributed and logically
modular so let's now that we're all on
the same page hopefully about those
terms let's jump into these 10 most
common mistakes that I've seen companies
make over and over
again the first one maybe this one won't
surprise you at this point in the stock
but number one is assuming that
microservices are always
best there's uh some great books out
there about microservices maybe you've
read some of them Sam Newman from the UK
has created one that's really excellent
he says in that book that if you're
going to do microservices you should
have a really good reason is what he
says now he goes into more detail to
describe some of the reasons that he
thinks are valuable reasons but uh I've
kind of outlined a few uh a few of the
downsides here if if uh you're trying to
do um if you're trying to do
microservices just because you're
looking for something that uh is
scalable while monoliths can be scalable
we talked about that already
microservices are really hard to do
based on my unscientific survey of our
clients who've come to us looking for
help I would say over 90% of
microservice projects are actually some
kind of a distributed
monolith nowadays it's such a buzzword
but nobody's really been doing
microservices for 10 years or anything
like that so probably there's nobody on
your team who says oh I've built dozens
of successful microservices I know
exactly what to do so you're trying to
figure it out and when you try and
figure it out you very likely if you
haven't been to my talk will make some
of these 10 mistakes and it's very easy
to end up in the wrong place and then
finally uh the wrong reasons to create a
distributed
monolith so what are some good reasons I
talked a little bit about independent
scalability so scaling different parts
of the application talked a little bit
about independent deployability if you
have to be able to take parts of the
application down frequently while you're
leaving other parts up I attended a
devops talk a while back with a an
Amazon engineer he was talking about at
the time for amazon.com the e-commerce
site they were doing tens of thousands
of updates to the website every day tens
of thousands of releases happening in a
day now if you had a monolith you
basically your application would be down
all day right like a lot of my builds
take four or five minutes and then it
takes another minute or two to do the
release you couldn't even do 10,000 in a
day if it takes that long your
application would be down all day long
right they need to at Amazon they need
to be able to do independent
deployability they need to be able to
update parts of the application without
taking any of the rest of it down
because they would lose millions in you
know 50 seconds if they were down right
uh isolating the surface area of failure
if you have part of your application
that takes orders or it's where the
money comes from for your business you
probably want to make sure that that is
as isolated as possible from all the
other systems you might want to have
cues uh event driven de you know
development going on behind the scenes
so that it can take orders even if all
the other systems are down for a whole
day and just cue them up so that's
something that you can do much easier
with microservices and then I mentioned
it a couple times but independent teams
if you have 60 developers or 100
developers and they're all working on a
very large application but they're all
kind of focused in different areas of
that application well then it makes a
lot of sense for that team to work on a
microservice there's a big trade-off
with microservices which if you only
remember one thing from this talk I want
it uh to be the last thing which is that
microservices
aren't always the right thing for every
project if you only remember two have it
be this one microservices are inherently
bad at immediate consistency they have
something called eventual consistency
they're very good if they're designed
well at something called High
availability so microservices someone
can trip over the power cord in the
server room and bring down one of the
microservices and all of the other ones
are still fine someone can write some
bad code and deploy it to one of the
microservices all of the other
microservices will still run but because
of that distributed nature of a
microservices architecture all of the
different applications are going to get
data updated to them eventually that's
that eventual consistency monoliths
usually will have a single data store or
at least a single data store per uh per
like data Shard and because of that
they'll have a immediate consistency as
soon as you finish the database trans
trans action of writing then everything
in the application is aware of that new
data that's been written to the database
they can now read those updates right so
if you want High availability
microservices might be the right
architecture for you if you want
eventual I'm sorry immediate consistency
then monoliths might be the right
architecture for you I mentioned this
when I was showing you what the typical
architecture looks like for a
distributed monolith but very commonly I
see the data store the database being
shared between the different
microservices another one that you might
have not thought of though is the data
models themselves the models that
represent that data those data stores so
imagine you have this
scenario where you're building uh what
you intend to be microservices you have
all these different services but they're
sharing a database and service one over
here has a team that says you know we
need to make a breaking change to this
table in the database but it's our table
it belongs to our microservice so we
should be able to make breaking changes
to it because we can update the code and
we can deploy those changes all together
so they go ahead and break something in
the in the schema of this
database now even if you set out to not
share databases as soon as as share
tables even as soon as you have the same
database uh I guarantee it'll happen
I've seen so many projects start out
where they said well we'll each have our
own schema in the database and we'll
have different logins with different
security and what ends up happening is
somebody gets lazy and says I really
need that table and I don't want to wait
for an event to publish the information
from one service to another I'm just
going to I'm like already connected to
this database I'm just going to do a
real quick select statement and get that
information right from the database
it'll definitely happen if you allow
everybody to connect to the same
database so what happens when team one
breaks the schema well team five over
here
didn't know about it and maybe team one
didn't know that team five was cheating
and looking at the schema of a table
that belonged to team one so now
microservice 5 just broke so is this
High availability is this independent
applications no right it's very easy
when you're sharing a database to
accidentally break things so what do we
want it to look like we want it to look
like this every application has its own
database if they need to share
information they should do that through
uh asynchronous method like an event bus
this is the you know quote unquote right
way to do microservices that will not
create coupling between these different
microservices let's look at a example of
data models as well so imagine you're
writing all of your code in C for all of
these microservices and you're used to
doing monoliths so a lot of your
applications you'll have these like
massive uh Visual Studio Solutions with
20 50 Pro projects in them right
and you're used to doing things that way
so when you start creating microservices
you do the same you create a class
library and it has all of your uh model
data models in it and everyone can
access that that's kind of how you would
normally do it in a monolith well in
microservices that should probably be
actually separate libraries one for each
and I know that Al sort of like the DBA
I was talking about earlier that sounds
like it's breaking all the rules that
you've learned over the years about how
to design good architecture uh right
everyone's learned dry don't repeat
yourself in good coding and uh if you're
doing microservices correctly you
probably do need to repeat yourself so
imagine this scenario I just stayed in a
hotel since I'm visiting from the US
imagine that the hotel I stayed in has
microservices for all their their
different parts of their business they
want to be able to take reservations all
the time because they want to uh they
don't want that part to go down so it's
maybe it's a good fit for microservices
for them to use this and they've got
maintenance and housekeeping and maybe
some other microservices in
there they've got obviously a hotel room
object is going to be a really important
one in their data model so right now all
of those services are sharing that same
model for their uh hotel room data it's
got information in it like is it
occupied currently it's got how many
beds are in there it's got how long it
takes to clean uh maybe it has like a
related entity that's like a child
entity that's like the repair history in
that room uh or maintenance requests or
something like
that so now what happens if the
housekeeping service says you know we
don't really care how many seconds it
takes to clean a room we care how many
minutes so we're going to go ahead and
update that from a float to an INT be a
little bit less accurate but it's plenty
enough accuracy for us to know how long
to plan for every room to be cleaned so
they make that change well if everyone's
sharing the same data model before they
do an update to their system everyone
else is going to have to do an update to
their system because now they have the
wrong type that's not going to match uh
the model is not going to match their
data stores because maybe all these
other microservices are still using a
float for that minutes to clean property
so because of this what you actually
want to do is you want to split these
data models up ideally you would put the
data in only the place that it's needed
and then copy it to all the other places
through events uh if other places need
that information as well so in this
example I have the hotel room under
reservations whether it's
occupied and the number of beds I have a
different hotel room under maintenance
that just has the repair history and I
have a different hotel room under
housekeeping with just the minutes to
clean so you might already be asking
like well what about those examples Jay
where there's data that all of these
applications need so here's an example
let's say you have an admin service
that's like your backend administrative
interface where people can do things
like creating new hotel rooms maybe
there's been an ex expansion to the
hotel and there's now some new rooms
that you want to add to your hotel so
you go into your admin module and you
hit this service that adds a new hotel
room it stores in the admin module the
admin module then will create a event
let's say it's like a hotel room created
event that it will publish onto the
queue or bus and then anybody that has
subscribed to that event will get that
event and DEP depending on what
technology you use down here for your
event bus you can make it so that even
if these other services are down for
maintenance that they will get this when
they come back online they will get
these events you can you know make
guaranteed delivery so so all of these
subscribers will get this
information and they can now update
their own copies of this data to say I
now know about hotel room
124 uh last you know the last I knew
that the hotel rooms only went up to 123
and now I know about hotel room 124 I'll
go ahead and create a record for those
in my part of the system as well so
that's kind of how you would do it with
the event bus and without sharing your
data models
mistake number three is microservices
that are too
big hopefully many of you are already
familiar with DDD or domain driven
design and development uh if you are not
this is a great book that you can use to
get started learning about it it's a
large and fairly complicated topic so we
don't really have time to talk about it
in a lot of detail today but I do want
to mention that if you're trying to
figure out where do I draw the lines
between different micro services and
what goes in this one what goes in that
one what you really want to use is this
concept of bounded contexts which comes
from domain driven design it's uh pretty
tricky and it takes some time to get
used to so I recommend starting with
this there's also some other great books
about it that um I'm sure you'll be
recommended on Amazon as soon as you add
this to your
cart I have a simple rule since we don't
have time to get into you know two hours
of domain driven design and development
cont uh stuff right now my simple rule
is that you're trying to create the
smallest possible micro service without
creating chatty communication between
your
services now I'll give you an example of
this after my next problem which maybe
predictably is microservices that are
too small so let's imagine an example
where you have been to a conference they
talked about microservices you said I'm
going to microservice everything from
now on I'm micros servicing all the
things and what what's more micro than a
single endpoint per service right I'm
not going to make all these mistakes
that Jay was talking about I'm GNA make
the micest service I can so I'm going to
even have my user login endpoint be one
service and my password reset be a
different service doesn't get more micro
than that right well what is the problem
with this every time logs into that
system you they might fail and you want
to maybe keep count of how many times
they failed if they fail five times in
10 minutes maybe you want to force them
to password reset well that means that
every time someone logs in and fails
that information has to be synchronized
between these two systems it also means
that they might fail really fast and it
might take a couple minutes for that
information to get over to the other
system so they might be locked out of
their account and then have to wait to
reset their password until that system
finds out about it so basically you're
creating this kind of chattiness between
these two services or even if you're
using an event bus there's a lot of
events going into that event bus and a
lot of um subscribers to those events
basically anytime something happens in
one the other one cares about it anytime
it happens in this one that one cares
about it too so that's too chatty I
think that's clearly too chatty so
somewhere right in the middle is kind of
what you're aiming for for the right the
right place to break up your
microservices if you have too much inner
service communication you're going to
have a very slow application with a lot
of data
latency and if you have your service
size too big well then you really don't
have microservices eventually if they
get big enough they just become a
monolith again right so somewhere in the
middle is kind of where you want to set
that
line the fifth problem that I see is a
lot of people starting a green field
project as
microservices why is that a problem well
Greenfield microservices is actually
harder than Brownfield
microservices if you're not familiar
with those terms Greenfield basically
mean starting from scratch or starting a
new project and Brownfield is migrating
something
existing the reason why it's harder is
four things number one you have if you
have existing code even if it's a
monolith even if it's a bad monolith you
have all of the relationships already
documented on how the different parts of
the application works you could even do
maybe an object diagram or a database
diagram and see very clear places where
you could actually break your
microservices apart if you've ever done
a database uh relationship diagram
you've seen all those relationship
arrows between all the database tables
you know that there'll be like a little
clump of tables that have lots of
interaction with each other and then
there'll be like maybe one line that'll
go up to this group over here right that
one line is kind of your indication that
oh this might be a good place to break
these microservices up if there's an
existing system there's also someone to
talk to hopefully if they haven't left
the company from having to maintain a
ball of mud
monolith uh there's someone to talk to
that knows how the system works also the
system already Works maybe it doesn't
work great but what's the number one
thing that stops us from doing a good
job with software
engineering time right there's always
deadlines uh has anyone ever had a
project where the their boss said you
can get this done whenever you want no
no so what's really great about having a
system that already works even if it's
not great maybe it's slow maybe it's not
ideal in some ways but it works it buys
you time to do microservices carefully
so that you don't make some of these
mistakes that we're talking about and
then the last last one I think is a
really important one it's the ability to
have a baseline to compare to you're
trying to migrate to microservices
theoretically because you're trying to
make a better system than the system
that you had before and if you're trying
to migrate to microservices wouldn't it
be nice to have a system that you could
actually measure against to say are we
making something better or are we
actually making something worse uh and
that's something that you have when
you're doing a Brownfield
migration there's a bunch of different
approaches the Brownfield migration if
you've been in any of the other talks
about microservices I know they've
mentioned some of these the Strangler
fig pattern is often put forward as the
best one which I would agree with it
actually comes from this really crazy
plant that's in I think Australia that
starts growing in the tops of trees and
it shoots these Vines down the
trees when the vines get to the ground
they'll go into the ground and they'll
wrap around the trees roots and they'll
actually choke that tree off so it
doesn't get the water or nutrients that
it needs from the ground anymore
eventually that tree dies and it just is
like a backbone for the vine so that it
can get access to the sun which is up
high so it's kind of a violent slow
motion violent example but it's actually
a really good analogy for how you can do
a migration gradually from a legacy
application to a modern application if
you create a facade layer you could
imagine this being like an API Gateway
or something you can start with a very
small application and a very large
Legacy application maybe it's 100%
Legacy and 0% modern and you can
gradually move endpoints from one to the
other rewrite them in the modern
application all that time you're
updating your facade your maybe your API
Gateway so that the client applications
are never aware of any of these changes
it all looks exactly the same to them
and everything continues to work the way
it did before but eventually you finish
migrating and this buys you the time to
basically put your
application uh out with updates to it
right away without having to finish the
whole thing and might you know wait
three years while you're migrating it to
microservices problem number six is
creating coupling through cross cutting
concerns some of the common cross
cutting concerns that microservices have
are all of the security or authorization
and authentication related things
logging is a common one if you're going
to debug a microservices application
where a user interacts with this
microservice which updates its database
and publishes an event to a bus and then
three things subscribe to that event and
they update something in their database
you can imagine if something goes wrong
it's going to be really hard to figure
out if you don't have really good
logging it's going to be hard to figure
out what happened so logging is very
important but it's also very difficult
to do it in a way that doesn't create
coupling between those microservices and
and then the last one is
configuration so my general advice with
this is to not reinvent the wheel uh
I've given this talk maybe 20 times in
the last two years and almost every time
someone has come up to me afterwards and
said we're doing microservices and we
created our own event
bus uh my first response to that is
that's really cool you probably should
not create your own event bus no offense
I'm sure you're great engineer uh but
these problems have been solved they
seem really interesting and cool to
solve uh it's the type of thing that
would get an engineer very excited to
say oo I know how to do that I know how
to do publish And subscribe and I'll
write events into a database and I can
do this to make sure that guaranteed
delivery works I guarantee you will not
do as good a job as Kafka or Azure event
bus or any of the other services that
exist out there that already do this
same thing for logging there's a logging
Library called seek
seq that is built for doing distributed
logging it's built to be Loosely coupled
fault tolerant it can queue up events
even if the storage uh the place it's
storing the logs goes offline it can
store them for a while and then uh write
them when that the log becomes available
again and most importantly their
technology it's technology agnostic
which means you're not tying in all of
your teams to some particular technology
stack by saying oh we created our own
logger class in C
now everybody has to write their
microservice in C right uh or we created
it in whatever language but put it in
new now you have to do it in net you
can't write it in some other
language so uh don't reinvent the wheel
when it comes to these cross cutting
concerns uh there similarly are things
out there for authentication and
authorization I'm sure you've heard of
ooth and those types of things uh and
logging I recommend seek and there's
other services out out there for
configuration as
well number seven is the use of
synchronous communication this is
maybe maybe the worst one uh so I told
you that story at the beginning of a
client that was uh coming to us with a
microservices application that was
performing poorly their biggest problem
was this problem they also had a bunch
of the other ones we talked about but
this was the main reason why their
system per performed so po so poorly
so just give you an example here imagine
you have a ORD service and a customer
service these are in separate
microservices from each other your
orders endpoint wants to take an order
it might get a customer ID and it needs
to look up that customer's billing
address and mailing address and whatever
other information you need for the order
so it's really tempting to do something
like this where you start out the order
you say oh I need to look up that
customer I'm going to do a HTTP call or
a call to this database to get that
customer data while you're obviously
waiting for that customer data the ORD
service is
blocked and then that customer data
comes back in an ideal situation that
customer idea uh ID is found and that
customer comes back and you can process
the order now if you're only having one
concurrent user this works great and so
usually when you're developing and
you're testing this on your development
environment no problem
imagine what happens when this service
either goes down for maintenance or has
some sort of an issue or slows down
significantly because of load now your
order service is blocked maybe forever
if it's if the service is if the
customer service is down maybe it's just
blocked for a lot longer time because
the customer's service has gotten busy
this is actually what happened in that
application I was telling you about and
it basically leads to this situation
where if you have arrows between all of
your services where every service is
relying on several other services and
one goes down on purpose or on accident
then all the ones that rely on that are
now either slow or down and then the all
the ones that rely on that become slow
or go down and pretty soon you have
nothing working anymore this is exactly
what happened in that application I was
telling you about one single service
would get slow and it didn't matter
which one it was it could be anyone
whatever one you started hitting the
most uh we started doing some load
testing on that application we would
just hit any one service we would
randomly hit one with some load and all
of the other ones would slow down within
about 30 seconds and it was because of
this situation everybody was waiting for
everybody else and so this is obviously
not really a microservice because these
are not independent from each other at
all so there's obviously lots of great
alternatives to synchronous commun
Communication asynchronous Service bus
or cues are an important way to do that
uh it's probably the the best way to do
it another one is through polling it's
an option that you can use there's also
a pattern called the circuit breaker
pattern uh I would recommend this is
maybe like the worst case scenario if
you absolutely have to call from one
service to another service synchronously
you can at least use a circuit breaker
pattern the idea of the circuit breaker
pattern is you write some code that
wraps around that call and it keeps
track of failures so if there are five
failures in a minute calling service X
then that rapper class will actually
shut down and say all calls from to
service X are going to be disabled from
now I'm just going to return an error
every time which then at least speeds up
your application it starts getting
errors back right away instead of having
to wait for service X to
respond problem number eight is a really
nefarious one and that is actually
coupling your microservices to each
other through the events that they've
published this might even not seem
possible to you at first blush but I've
seen this happen so basically the idea
is that your services should actually
publish events that say uh you know hey
this just happened in this service if
anybody else who cares about that can do
something about it here's some data
related to that event uh well what
happens later when the service that's
publishing that event decides they need
to make a change to that event right
well now there's a potential to break
all those services that were subscribed
to it so there's some very basic rules
that you'll find published a lot of
different places that talk about what to
do to make sure your events uh don't
break one of them the first one is rule
number
one uh no new required fields
so don't create a new field that's
required on an
event all optional Fields if they're new
so once a once a event has been
published the first time from then on
any Fields after that have to be
optional with a documented default
second rule is anybody subscribing to
something that sees an unrecognized
field should just ignore it but keep
processing right so like well that's a
new field I don't know what that means
because When I Was Written I that didn't
exist so I don't know what to do with it
I'm just going to ignore it but if I'm
going to publish an event about what I
just did I'm going to take that data and
I'm going to forward it on in my event
so that everyone else who might know
what that means knows what to do about
it rule number three consumers of
optional Fields use the default values
when they're missing right so if you get
a data uh field on an event that you
weren't written to know what it means
you're going to pass it on but you're
also going to use the default values uh
which should be published in the event
and then the last one is if you cannot
satisfy all three of those rules you
need to do a new event that maybe has a
new required field the solution to that
is to create a new type of event which
means that you might have to publish two
events now uh going back to my hotel
example every time a new room is added
maybe you've got a room created one and
room created two right because now
there's one that has some new required
fields that some Services know about and
some don't I often get a question about
how do you handle like this creates a
big mess it seems like how do you handle
this if you do true microservices and
you have actual separate teams working
on them my recommendation is to have
sort of like a event Council that has a
representative or a project lead or
Chief Architect or whatever from each of
those teams that meets on a regular
basis and talks about these events maybe
a day comes where you publish a new
event and you can tell everybody about
it maybe they want to put that in their
backlog to uh handle that event with
some of that new data in there or maybe
the day comes when an old event that you
were publishing isn't subscribed to by
anyone anymore because it's been
replaced and you can actually turn that
off that's something that you would find
out in in an event Council where you go
uh maybe once a month and everybody
talks about what events are being
published in
there problem number nine is not
automating the build and release cycle
you wouldn't believe how many companies
maybe maybe you would uh still don't
have automated cicd pipelines but when
we have a client come to us and say
we're considering microservices this is
one of the first questions we'll ask
them the very first one is why do you
want to do microservices and making sure
they have a very good reason the second
question is do you have automated uh
build and releases because if you don't
you're kind of avoiding the whole
benefit of microservices which is the
ability to update these things
frequently and independently and if
you're doing it manually that's very
time consuming and it's very prone to
error human error especially with things
like configuration or you know releasing
to the wrong environment at the wrong
time you want to have all of this stuff
automated first before you even think
about implementing
microservices the last last one which
I've alluded to several several times
throughout the talk is uh mismatched
teams I mentioned that Google defines
microservices architecture as both an
architecture and a team
organization and uh you might be
familiar with something called Conway's
law Conway's law to paraphrase it
basically says that a team that builds a
system will build a system that looks an
awful lot like that
team uh the common example that's always
given it's a bit of an oldfashioned
example but it's if you give four teams
the job of writing a compiler they'll
write a four pass compiler nobody's
going to volunteer and say well the work
our team did isn't really necessary
because it mostly overlaps with the work
the other teams did so go ahead and just
throw away what we wrote and just use
yours uh if you have four teams you're
probably going to get four stages to
your compilation process the same
applies to Modern applications if you're
building microservices but you're
building it with one team I can almost
guarantee that somebody is going to fall
for the temptation to put data in a
shared database or connect directly
through a synchronous HTTP call or
connect directly to another database or
something like that because everybody
knows the whole application everybody
works on the whole
application this is really just not a
good fit for microservices if you have
one team of five or six people and
that's it for your whole
organization it probably doesn't make a
lot of sense to do microservices unless
each person is doing their own totally
independently of each other and that
doesn't make a lot of sense so I would
say if that's what your team looks like
probably microservices automatically are
not the right fit for you you want your
team to look more like this if you're
doing microservices you want to have a
team for each microservice now I'm not a
purist it doesn't have to be 100% like
this you might have two micro services
that are a little smaller and they can
be kind of grouped together and assigned
to a single team but the idea is that
every team has their microservice or
microservices that they're in charge of
and there's really not a lot of cross
contamination between
those all right so that brings us to the
end of my list of 10 things so hopefully
what you walked away what you're going
to walk away from this with is that
monoliths can be good too you can
actually scale those if you need to
microservices are great for the right
type of applications but if you don't
have a really good reason to use them
they're very dangerous and there's a
very good chance you'll build a
distributed
monolith even if you think microservices
could be a good fit if this is a brand
new application consider building it as
a monolith first and then migrating it
at some point in the future there's a
lot of advantages to using that
process if you have a single team that's
small
probably a monolith is the best fit for
you if you have a large team where it
would make sense for it to be split up
into little groups then maybe
microservices is a good fit for that
team and then finally when you are
implementing microservices hopefully you
remember some of these 10 common
mistakes that I showed you uh to make
sure that you don't fall into those same
traps so that brings us to the end of my
content and we've still got a few
minutes left so uh I know there's some
microphones in the back and I'd be happy
to take any questions that anyone is
willing to say out loud in front of
everyone any questions I can
answer you can just raise your hand or Y
there's the microphone is
ready any questions I answered
everyone's questions so perfectly in my
talk that you don't have any questions
all right well if you think of something
and you want to chat afterwards I'll be
up here for a little bit uh before I
have to hop on a Train to Lisbon but uh
you can also reach out to me at any of
these places or feel free to use this to
join me for my office hours I'd be happy
to chat with you at some time that's
convenient for both of our time zones
thanks so much for coming to the talk
today I hope it was useful for
[Applause]
you